hello everyone so the results of j mains
and j advanced are both out and the
jawsa counselling has just started so i
thought that this will be a good time
for me to share a few tips with you so
that you can make an informed decision
before filling in your choices i'm
making this video particularly because
over the years both as a faculty member
and previously when i was a uh when i
was an undergraduate student here at iit
kharagpur i've seen many of my friends i
have seen many of my students as a
faculty
suffering a lot because of the wrong
decisions that they made at the time of
counseling or even if they did not
suffer explicitly because of those wrong
decisions they at least regretted their
decisions later in life
so i do not want the same kind of regret
or suffering to happen to you all and
therefore i'm making this video
now
at this point at the time of counseling
the fundamental question which arises in
all the students minds is
whether they should go with a particular
department or a particular institute
at this point most of you do not know
about
different departments so
probably in your mind there is a greater
preference of giving a greater weightage
to the institute but let me tell you
this
that this is a very wrong notion
you must always make it a point to give
greater preference to the department now
the natural question arises how can you
know about the department because you
have only
only been studying physics chemistry and
maths
you do not know about the departments
well for that there's a very easy way
out
you go to the website of the institute
that you are interested in or for that
matter go to any good institute website
look up what is being taught in the
different departments go to the
mechanical engineering website go to the
chemical engineering website and look it
up
and let me tell you this you will be
very surprised by what you find there
okay for example
although i'm not from chemical injury
myself but i know for a fact that there
is always a lot of wrong notion
associated with chemical engineering
because of the word chemical written in
chemical engineering perhaps they do not
like chemistry uh did not they did not
like studying chemistry in their plus
too so they never go for chemical
engineering nothing can be further from
the truth
because in chemical engineering a lot of
emphasis is there on transport phenomena
in general particularly on heat transfer
mass transfer fluid mechanics where
there's a lot of importance on
fundamental mechanics and so chemical
engineering has a lot of overlap with
mechanical engineering now after you
have taken a look at the websites of the
different departments what you need to
do is try to correlate what is being
taught there the different topics which
are being emphasized in the different
departments with what you actually like
studying during your plus two
let me point this out very clearly i'm
asking you to identify the favorite
topics from your plus two not the topics
on which you ended up scoring highly
because it may so happen that you ended
up probably scoring higher in some of
the topics which you're probably not
that much interested in studying for the
long haul and this long haul is a very
important thing when you choose a
department when you go into a department
it is for your entire life
okay so
choose a topic in which you will have
the patience the stamina to study long
and hard okay and if you have that
fundamental interest
okay forget the scores that you manage
during your plus two if you have that
fundamental interest in those topics i
assured you okay i assured you that you
will be able to do well in the long run
and this long run is what matters in the
professional environment okay once you
go into professional
practice that is what is going to matter
and even just considering the
undergraduate days your undergraduate
degree a period of four years for five
years for dual degree programs is not a
long is not a very short period of time
so you have to sustain your interest and
efforts over those four five years
another very very important point uh
again to do with the with this dilemma
between department and institute is that
i've seen many students what they do is
they take up a their they they try their
best to go to their dream institute
because everyone certainly has some kind
of a dream institute they try to go to
their dream institute at the uh
with with the notion that okay whatever
department i will get i'll just go
okay this is completely wrong this is
especially wrong
if you are such a student and you are
thinking that i will let me go to the
depart to the institute first and then
depend on the provision of department
change to hope that after your first
year you'll be able to change your
department to something which you really
desire this is completely completely
wrong okay this is actually a big trap
this is a big trap because i have seen
many students who get stuck with a
department which they have absolutely no
desire in studying with the only
compensating fact is that they are in
their dream institute
but they
end up regretting their decision all
throughout their life they completely
lose their interest they completely lose
their interest in studying in academics
and they end up doing some random job
which is which has nothing to do with
with the department that they had chosen
back at the time of counseling so please
please do not fall into this trap
sacrifice your favorite institute your
dream institute and choose something
which you really want to study
academically next let us talk about some
examples
first and foremost my own department
mechanical engineering so for mechanical
engineering uh you definitely have to be
good in mechanics that's a given
now as i said earlier uh
if you're really interested in studying
mechanics and i know many of you are i
many of you develop a lot of interest in
studying mechanics but somehow many of
you do not end up scoring very high
marks uh in mechanics related questions
because of whatever reasons despite that
if you have a genuine interest in
mechanics i think mechanical engineering
or aerospace engineering or civil
engineering is the way to go please also
remember that mechanical engineering is
not just about mechanics okay there is a
lot of stuff beyond
mechanics all the mechanics is the
fundamental thing
there is thermodynamics okay which is
another very fundamental thing so if you
like thermodynamics uh definitely
mechanical engineering also chemical
engineering
uh certainly aerospace engineering next
let us talk about everyone's favorite
computer science and engineering
well
if you managed to get a high enough rank
you are
of course driven by all the media hype
and all the previous year's trends to go
into computer science and engineering
but
do think twice
if it so happens that your high rank is
as a result of your excellent
performance in physics and chemistry but
not in maths
okay because if you have to do really
well in the long term
uh in computer science and engineering
you really really have to be good in
maths and the kind of maths which has to
do more perhaps more
on the side of pure maths of course
there's a lot of applied maths in
computer science and entering too
but some of the fundamental things
especially on the theoretical side of
computer science you have to be good on
the pure math side of things things like
number theory uh coming to real
mathematics and so on
okay so please be mindful of that
uh
similarly for uh maths and computing
there's a lot of craze about about maths
and computing uh in fact we have an
entire department here at iit kharagpur
on maths and computing
and people are very much interested in
studying that nowadays but please note
that beyond that hype ultimately when
you take this department you have you
are the one who have to study the
various subjects
okay it's not just artificial
intelligence or one or two subjects
which you have to study you'll also have
to study very fundamental subjects
like
real analysis and many other uh very
very very classical topics like topology
so
you have to really have a proper
mathematical bent of mind to be able to
do well overall in mathematics and
computing okay so please bear that in
mind also another very very important
fact which many people do not realize
early on is that they are excited by
certain department okay so nowadays
there is the uh i mean you can find all
information on the internet and
there is no dirt of
various kinds of exciting videos on
youtube various kinds of uh videos also
which suggest uh
like small projects which you can try
out on your own and perhaps you have
already tried that on your own out of
your own initiative that's excellent and
based on those things you are perhaps
interested in a particular department
maybe you are interested in mechanical
engineering maybe interested in
electrical
but
uh
you have to understand something
that when you go into an undergraduate
program from the very first day you will
not be able to do such kind of exciting
projects because this is a serious
program every undergraduate program in
in in engineering in science definitely
it's a very very serious program which
builds up your knowledge step by step
and so when you have to do this
over years maybe over the entire first
year second year third year you have to
study some of the very classical very
fundamental things in these departments
okay and
you have to build up the the abcs of the
knowledge so
the initial studies that you do in these
departments uh even if you you take an
informed decision based on your own
interest about joining a department
it may not be that much exciting
let me tell you this that
um the very fact that you have
successfully cleared j mains or j
advanced means that you are a good
problem solver so you like very much
solving challenging problems
now
suppose you go into a department like
biotechnology or geology and geophysics
initially there will be a lot of the
topics uh over the semesters over the
initial semesters which may be
information heavy because the professors
there have to first teach you some of
the abcs of the subject only then they
can give you some kind of interesting uh
topics where there will be a they'll be
very creative kind of problem solving
like you cannot go for creative kind of
problem solving without first building
your own knowledge without first
building that abc is the fundamentals of
the subject so for that you have to
really study hard patiently uh like
putting in your full stamina of your
studiousness okay many people do not
understand this they get bored by the
things so when you pick a certain
department
even if it is based on your own interest
please be aware that this is going to
happen
okay if you have the stamina the the the
tenacity to and to first build that
knowledge and only then go for creative
kind of problem solving and projects
interesting projects uh
only then go for these kinds of uh
departments and if you're really
interested in in problem solving from
day one
well the easy answer is join mechanical
engineering okay so right from day one
right from day zero you'll be given
problems uh
to solve okay because it's just the
nature of the subject that you cannot
learn mechanics okay the kind of higher
mechanics that you are going to learn in
mechanical engineering without actually
solving problems the so the abcs of the
subjects is actually taught through
problems uh so uh there is uh
there is the truth okay there is the set
of truths for you to to really digest
think about and based on these kinds of
small tips that i have shared with you i
hope uh you'll be able to make an
informed decision and
uh
go into a department go into an
institute uh which will be
the perfect solution to this
uh to this
to what is actually a nice optimization
problem okay so this this jake and this
jaw counselling selecting the department
and the institute is ultimately not a
maximization problem it is ultimately an
optimization problem better here it's a
constrained optimization problem and i
hope you get the perfect solution to
this optimization problem so all the
best
thank you